when allegations surfaced regarding
workplace statements that triggered some
complaints against woody johnson the
owner of the new york jets not in the
jets workplace but
in his capacity as the u.s ambassador to
great britain jamal adams took to
twitter to call out the owner of the
team and i said yesterday hey you're
trying to you're trying to get out you
do whatever you have to do to try to get
out well it didn't work to call out the
owner shireen so now jamal adams
speaking to manish meta of the new york
daily news calls out adam gase i don't
feel like he's the right leader for this
organization to reach the promised land
as a leader what really bothers me is
that he doesn't have a relationship with
everybody in the building at the end of
the day he doesn't address the team if
there's a problem in the locker room he
lets another coach address the team if
we were playing crappy and we're losing
he doesn't address the entire team as a
group at halftime he'll walk out of the
locker room and let another coach handle
it ow boom bang but the motivation is
obvious jamal wants out so he's doing
whatever he has to do to try to get out
well and he also said that they've given
him the okay that if they get a deal
good enough they will trade jamal adams
but the jets want too much in a trade
for jamal adams they're not going to get
that i mean dallas offered them a first
round draft pick at the draft and they
turned that that down and so they're
they're asking for a lot more than that
and i just don't see them getting what
they want for jamal adams so i don't
know where this ends i don't know if
he's going to hold out and and not show
up and they don't trade him and it's a
le'veon bell type situation i don't know
what's going to happen here but
they're not going to get what they want
for jamal adams in a trade unless they
come down a long way in what they
they're asking for
and shireen jamal adams also told manish
that jamal will be showing up for my
teammates when training camp opens he
wants to be with an organization that
wants to win and do things the right way
but he will show up and look he's
looking at a 50 000
fine per day if he doesn't show up you
immediately lose a year of credit toward
free agency now there isn't that you
have to show up before 30 days prior to
the start of the regular season that was
the old donut hole where a guy who
wasn't a vested veteran could hold out
for a little while before jeopardizing a
year of credit toward free agency so for
all those reasons he will show up and
for all the reasons you stated i don't
think the jets are going to be able to
trade him and on top of it if you come
close to giving the jets what they want
jamal adams wants a new contract and
even though the texans did it with
laramie tunsil and the rams did it with
jaylen ramsey it doesn't make it not
stupid to do that you don't trade for a
guy like that without getting the
contract done and who's going to give
out a new contract shireen in the middle
of a pandemic it ain't going to happen
jamal adams isn't going to get what he
wants the jets aren't going to get what
they want so they got to find a way to
get through it this year
well and we saw what happened we saw
what happened with jalen ramsey last
year yet yes he was on the team as you
said he showed up but hey he was
suddenly had all sorts of injuries where
he didn't play we could see that with
jamal adams too so there's no guarantee
he's going to be on the football field
for games
and you just wonder you know his passion
his desire he wants to be there for his
teammates you know it had to be
difficult for jaylen ramsey to thread
that needle because there is a
perception you're quitting on your
teammates will jamal adams do what
jaylen ramsey did last year i don't
think every player is wired in a way to
pull that off jamal adams just wants to
play football at the end of the day and
i think that will overcome any desire to
work the business
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports